it is time to celebrate the grand
opening of Chapman Dodge Chrysler Jeep
Ram the sponsors of this next segment
with a great selection and unheard of
savings and here to tell us more is my
friend Don Hamrick the president of
Nevada operations welcome back nice to
see you Mercedes been too long I know
it's so good to see you and big things
happening over in your neck of the woods
tell us tell us about the grand opening
so we're going to celebrate and when we
built this new facility 70 000 square
feet just an amazing store and our
customers are loving it our employees
are coming in with big smiles on their
faces so why not have a grand opening
sale and now we know it is huge like you
said seventy thousand square feet but
tell us about some of the the perks and
the amenities in this store so we've got
I the service department is completely
enclosed it's a covered area when
clients come in beautiful customer
Lounge I've got employee break room for
our technicians 24 000 square feet of
Parts
all the new items for our clients to
enjoy with the vehicles that we've got
laid out we're doing some special
accessorize on the new Jeep product as
well so there is just a lot of fun over
there well not only is the facility
beautiful but it's beautiful when you go
to a car dealership and you see fully
stocked
parking lot and that's what you guys
have which is not easy to find these
days yeah sometimes you see a car
dealership you think they're selling
asphalt they're just open we have got
extra cars as a result and that's what's
allowing us to do these extra specials
so you know ten thousand dollars off
Rams nobody else is doing that uh seven
thousand off Jeep Grand Cherokees and a
minimum of two thousand off every other
new vehicle we're going to make sure
that if you want a new car during the
month of October we're going to make
your deal so good you're going to love
it okay so let's talk a little bit about
financing because I know that can be a
tough area especially interest rates are
going up what kind of uh financing so we
are have we have several vehicles with
72 percent excuse me 72 months zero
percent so six years is zero percent
financing so you'll see some zero
percents out there but they're for 24
months and let's do your payments too
expensive 72 months at zero percent is
extraordinary and we have that on
several of our vehicles so it's very
exciting great time to buy a car that is
a absolutely incredible and unheard of
that if people are interested where are
you located so 3470 Boulder Highway is
the location for the new store our
second dealership is getting remodeled
completely that will be ready in January
but in the meantime that's where you
find us Boulder Highway and Sahara it's
the original Dodge store that opened in
the 60s but it's all brand new now oh
everything is new and it sounds
fantastic thank you so much Dawn and
thank you to Chapman Dodge a Chrysler
Jeep Ram for sponsoring this segment you
got to check them out call
702-457-1061 or visit
lasvegasdodge.com to learn more and
again they have that special offer ten
thousand dollars off new Rams seven
thousand dollars off new Jeep Grand
Cherokees and at least two thousand
dollars off every other vehicle Las
Vegas now we'll be right back